pour le grand public toutes les drogues
sont les mêmes tu finis à la rue
complètement camée pour la science c'est
différent chaque molécule a des effets
spécifiques alors on va expliquer tout
ce qui se passe chimiquement dans ton
corps et comment ça peut te transformer
à vie quels sont les effets du cannabis
sur ton cerveau 46 % des Français en ont
déjà fumé dans la plante on trouve une
molécule très spéciale le THC qu'est-ce
qu'elle a de particulier elle ressemble
beaucoup à une autre molécule produite
naturellement dans ton corps la
nandidamide le but de la langue d'amide
est de rééquilibrer chimiquement ton
cerveau ça combat le stress la douleur
et même la faim normalement la molécule
agit très rapidement puis disparaît mais
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si on
prolongeait son temps d'action la nombre
d'Amid vous ralentirez un lourd
sentiment d'apaisement exactement comme
le THC on dit en termes scientifique que
le THC est un agoniste du récepteur de
la nombre d'amide 10 plus simplement le
THC se déguise en une autre molécule de
ton corps si la langue d'amide il n'y a
pas besoin d'avoir exactement la même
forme juste un petit morceau en fait
votre cerveau marche comme avec des clés
et des serrures à l'extrémité de vos
neurones vous avez une immense surface
pleine de récepteurs qui activent plein
de choses différentes si vous avez la
bonne clé vous testez quelques serrures
et vous finirez par trouver la bonne ça
active le signal et donc produit l'effet
il se trouve que le THC peut ouvrir le
récepteur de la nomzanide mais la clé
reste coincée plus longtemps que prévu
le signal est envoyé en permanence outre
le fait que vous soyez hight ça va avoir
un deuxième effet chambouler la balance
entre glutamate et GABA c'est quoi
encore ces deux molécules voyez les
comme des feux de signalisation le
glutamate c'est le feu vert il active
vos neurones le Gabal lui les freine il
permet de calmer ceux qui sont trop
excités il faut une balance entre les
deux surtout dans les régions de votre
cerveau qui produisent la dopamine la
molécule de la récompense une sensation
de plaisir de travail bien fait vous
faisant croire que c'est bon pour vous
le THC ne va pas directement agir
là-dessus mais plutôt ralentir la
production de GABA le feu rouge
disparaît la production de dopamine n'a
plus aucun frein les robinets sont
grands ouverts vous vous noyez dans la
dopamine le plaisir oui mais au bout
d'un moment il y aura plus de dopamine
dans la réserve non alors les filles
s'arrêtera pas exactement tant qu'il y a
du THC vous neurones ne seront jamais à
court de dopamine tu en produit à
l'infini juste qu'à force de sur
solliciter vos neurones votre cerveau va
s'auto réguler et va détruire des
récepteurs à dopamine c'est pour ça que
refumer juste après vous fera moins fait
alors vous serez tenté d'augmenter la
dose mais c'est une erreur à force vos
neurones où on se fatiguer et mourir
vous perdez de la matière grise ce qui
va lourdement impacter votre mémoire et
vos capacités d'apprentissage des études
ont montré que si vous fumez
régulièrement avant vos 25 ans vous
perdez plusieurs points de cuit à vie
ouais bon moi le cannabis je l'utilise
pour me soigner man alors déjà si tu as
l'impression de fumer de fait du bien
c'est parce que tu es trompé par cette
dopamine artificielle et plus
concrètement ce n'est pas le THC qui te
soigne mais plusieurs autres molécules
dont le CBD il y a plusieurs études qui
montrent ses bénéfices et c'est légal
mais attends le THC le CBD les deux
molécules se ressemblent beaucoup non en
fait il suffit d'une petite différence
d'un atome et la clé ne rentre plus dans
la serrure l'action du CBD c'est plutôt
d'empêcher la dégradation de la
non-damide et comme elle a des effets
plus courts et moins puissants que le
THC on n'a pas l'effet a été nocif
attention par contre hein qu'importe que
vous fumez ça sera nocif pour vos
poumons quels sont les effets de
l'héroïne et de l'opium sur ton cerveau
l'opium c'est probablement la plus
ancienne des drogues connues on en
retrouve des traces sur des tablettes
sumériennes d'Elias 5000 ans à l'état
brut c'est du latex qu'on récolte du
pavosomnifères ingéré ça vous endort
engourdi vos sens et surtout réduit la
douleur parfait quand on devait vous
arracher une dent à l'époque c'est en
1804 qu'on va comprendre comment ça
marche dans le latex il y a une
particules très spéciale la morphine ça
a été une révolution qui a permis la
création de plein de médicaments
antidouleurs votre codoliprane et vos
sirop encore aujourd'hui contiennent un
dérivé de l'opium la codéine le problème
de la morphine c'est qu'elle passe très
mal la barrière protectrice du cerveau
ce qui limite ses effets alors les
chercheurs ont voulu rendre cette
morphine plus efficace qu'elle puisse
passer la barrière et qu'elle soit 100%
de ses effets c'est comme ça qu'ils ont
créé la diamorphine de son petit nom
l'héroïne oui à l'origine c'est un
médicament le plus puissant des
antidouleurs la diamorphine passe
facilement la barrière du cerveau puis
se retransforme en morphine normal
génial non pas vraiment concrètement
qu'est-ce qui se passe en l'état normal
votre corps produit naturellement de
l'endorphine c'est la clé pour ouvrir
les récepteurs au piacés dont les faits
de réduire la production de
noradrénaline elle c'est la molécule de
la survie elle contrôle votre attention
vos réflexes vos ressentis de la douleur
la sensation d'éveil le rythme cardiaque
et la respiration l'endorphine a l'effet
inverse elle vous endort c'est la
molécule pour ne pas survivre elle vous
empêche d'être un Rambo 24 heures sur 24
il se trouve que c'est justement ce que
fait la morphine elle se déguise en
endorphine par contre les deux molécules
se ressemblent pas du tout comme on l'a
dit l'important c'est pas d'être pareil
mais d'avoir la bonne forme de clé la
morphine elle va l'essentiel il y a pas
toute la grosse chaîne d'acides aminés
de l'endorphine ce qui la rend plus
efficace et plus agile outdoz vous
coupez totalement la noradrénaline votre
rythme cardiaque est respiratoire ne
sont plus régulés vous mourrez de
nouveau dose le problème c'est que le
cerveau s'habitue très vite à la
morphine plus le peinard on lui donne un
truc qui ressemble à de l'endorphine
sans devoir faire l'effort d'un produit
donc il devient paresseux et baisse la
production naturelle mais d'un autre
côté vu qu'il y a beaucoup trop de
morphine il va diminuer le nombre de
récepteurs
pour remplir proportionnellement plus de
serrure pour avoir le même effet plus
que ce que le corps ne peut gérer en
temps normal l'équilibre est détruit
c'est ça la coutumance du coup le jour
où vous arrêtez la morphine plus rien ne
contrôle la noradrénaline de couler à
flot les douleurs sont plus fortes vous
avez mal à la tête des crampes des
vertiges et puisque la morphine agit
aussi sur le circuit de la récompense
vous tombez dans le craving cette
furieuse envie de reconsommer ça peut
durer des semaines voire des mois avant
que le corps ne serait équilibre
sachez-le vous en avez déjà probablement
consommé des formes affaiblies que vous
trouvez dans des médicaments vendus en
pharmacie en cas de fracture grave avec
des douleurs intenses on peut vous
donner du fentanil très proche de
l'héroïne quels sont les effets de la
kétamine et du gaz hilarant sur ton
cerveau Natoo a fait une vidéo récemment
parlant de son opération pour un doigt
cassé pour la détendre à l'hôpital on
lui a proposé des spécial cas non pas
les céréales mais de la kétamine elle
décrit ça comme quelque chose de psy
unique avec des champignons qui dansent
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec du LSD ou
des champignons magiques la molécule a
des effets plus proches d'une drogue
vendue légalement ou supermarché dans
les années 1800 aux États-Unis était
commun de s'amuser en soirée avec du gaz
hilarant au rang puissant un ballon et
on lit exactement ce que font les jeunes
aujourd'hui avec ses capsules de
Chantilly que vous avez peut-être déjà
vu par terre dans la rue à l'intérieur
il y a du protoxyde d'azote une molécule
toute simple avec juste trois atomes
étant minuscule elle rentre facilement
partout dans votre corps respirez le
ballon et en quelques secondes vous en
avez dans le cerveau et le proto il aime
[ __ ] le boxon il va se déguiser en une
molécule encore plus petite produite
naturellement dans ton corps le monoxyde
d'azote c'est une clé pour bloquer les
récepteurs NMDA car s'ils sont tous
ouverts vous seriez trop stressés et
vous seriez incapable de dormir mais si
on en bloque trop alors vous allez
rigoler perdre la notion du temps avoir
l'impression de de partir dans des rêves
les yeux ouverts c'est ce que fait le
gaz hilarant il bouge tous vos
récepteurs lmda heureusement il est très
vite éliminé non sans causer quelques
dégâts au passage en détruisant de la
vitamine B12 et on a empêchant l'oxygène
d'arriver à ton cerveau ce qui peut
causer des dégâts réversibles et bien
sachez-le deux autres drogues agissent
sur la même mécanique le poppers d'abord
ces petits pots qu'on snif c'est en fait
d'une nitrile d'amyl qui va libérer du
monoxyde d'azote dont on parlait à
l'instant la deuxième drogue similaire
c'est bien sûr la kétamine qui a la
bonne forme de clé pour boucher les
récepteurs NMDA et vous voyez le
problème là où les petites molécules
s'éliminent rapidement la kétamine reste
et pour longtemps là où le gaz il avance
élimine en deux minutes la kétamine fait
effet pendant une heure
qui épuisent votre cerveau ça s'attaque
aussi à vos reins qui ont beaucoup de
difficultés à l'éliminer étonnamment à
petite dose la kétamine est étudiée pour
combattre les addictions oui oui vu que
c'est un dissociatif elle va séparer les
associations d'idées un alcoolique
associe la bière à une odeur une vision
un plaisir la kétamine va dissocier le
tout mais attention uniquement dans le
cadre de recherche médicale ça marchera
pas chez vous quels sont les effets du
LSD des champignons sur ton cerveau
est-ce que vous saviez que tous les
grands philosophes grecs avaient pris du
LSD Socrate Platon Aristote ils ont tous
plané comme des hippies à l'époque il
existait un culte secret les mystères
d'élusis il était strictement interdit
dans parlé on ne connaît quasi rien de
leur rythme sinon qu'à la sortie votre
vision du monde changeait à jamais vous
aviez vu les dieux l'archéologie a
permis de comprendre le pourquoi on a
retrouvé des traces de consommation de
blé infectées par le champignon seigle
qui produit une puissante molécule
hallucinogène c'est elle qui sera
synthétisée et modifié pour donner le
LSD par le célèbre Albert Hoffmann en
1938 toutes les civilisations ont leur
hallucinogène champignons crapauds
éponge de mer fleur cactus ioska on en
trouve partout dans la nature et devinez
quoi à chaque fois c'est la même chose
entre du LSD chimique et un champignon
hallucinogène c'est le même effet
biologique leur molécules actives ont
toute la bonne forme de clé et ce
qu'elles ouvrent c'est les récepteurs à
la sérotonine dont certains très
spéciaux la sérotonine c'est une
molécule importante pour ton corps elle
va te rendre heureux t'aider à
t'endormir ou calmer tes émotions si tu
en manques tu vas devenir plus instable
de plus dormir et avoir du mal à
mémoriser justement une étude a montré
que certaines formes d'autisme étaient
causées par un manque de récepteur à la
sérotonine mais attends si ces produits
naturellement par le corps pourquoi un
hallucine pas notamment alors déjà ça se
discute le processus des rêves étant lié
à la sérotonine pendant que vous dormez
vous faites un peu un giga triposide
alors que la journée vous n'activez
quasiment pas ces récepteurs sauf à
prendre des hallucinogènes le problème
c'est que le LSD va s'il accrocher
longtemps empêchant la circulation
rapide des informations elles vont
s'accumuler jusqu'à créer un
embouteillage de pensée tout finit par
se mélanger les couleurs vous paraissent
plus vive vous aurez l'impression que
les objets s'animent les formes et les
distances changent les perspectives sont
distordues c'est pour ça que le LSD
considéré comme le plus puissant
psychédélique sa clé est parfaite ses
effets durent jusqu'à 12 heures là où
les champignons sont plus rapidement
éliminés quand une substance active trop
longtemps en neurones c'est généralement
mauvais signe mais dans le cas des
hallucinogènes c'est un peu différent de
nouvelles connexions neuronales sont
créées comme une plante qui envoie ses
racines partout certains chercheurs
parlent même d'un engrais à neurone le
deuxième avantage c'est que ces
substances ne sont pas addictives vu que
le système de récompense n'est pas en
jeu il n'y a pas de sensation de manque
le troisième avantage c'est que
cloverdose est presque impossible en
2020 une femme a ingéré 55 mg de LSD
plus de 500 fois la dose récréative pour
info l'héroïne immortelle jusqu'à trois
fois la dose commune et bien avec le LSD
la femme n'a eu aucune séquelle elle dit
même qu'une de ces douleurs au pied a
disparu par contre il y a quand même
deux gros risques le premier c'est de
vous blesser pendant les hallucinations
le second c'est le bad trip avec des
troubles psychotiques proches de ce que
peut vivre un schizophrène il y a des
monstres qui vous entourent l'impression
d'être contrôlé par une machine d'être
coincé dans une boucle temporelle que
les gens savent ce que vous pensez des
flashbacks de votre traumatisme des
idées qui tournent en boucle et qui vous
donnent l'impression de se noyer dans
votre propre tête heureusement c'est
temporaire après vous avez peut-être
déjà entendu parler ces gens restaient
coincés une bonne partie de ces récits
sont des légendes destinées à vous faire
peur le LSD finit toujours par s'évacuer
de votre corps ok une partie peut rester
coincée dans les eaux et les graisses et
se libérer sans vous le vouliez c'est
les retours d'acide mais il faut
vraiment avoir énormément consommé pour
que ça soit un problème non le risque
c'est plutôt le réveil de
psychopathologie latente comme la
schizophrénie surtout si vous en prenez
jeune une personne peut avoir la maladie
endormie en elle dans des situations
particulières comme un stress intense
cette maladie peut se réveiller et être
dévastatrice pour toujours le LSD peut
déclencher ça plutôt que prévu mais tôt
ou tard ça serait arrivé quels sont les
effets de l'ecstasie cocaïne
émettanthétamine sur ton cerveau
sachez-le une boisson énergisante a
provoqué l'une des plus grandes crises
sanitaires au monde on est au Japon
début du 20e siècle et tout le monde
veut boire de l’éropode une boisson à
base d'une plante l'effet de rashinois
enfin plus exactement
d'une molécule modifiée à partir de
cette plante la méthamphétamine oui oui
la même substance que Breaking Bad on
peut la trouver dans la nature sous la
forme d'effetrine que les Japonais ont
transformé en mètres ouais c'est eux qui
l'ont inventé grâce à elle les ouvriers
pouvaient travailler des heures sans
dormir les soldats deviennent de vrais
machines à tuer le pays s'étend à la
moitié de l'Asie il deviennent les
maîtres du monde malgré ça ils perdront
la guerre et la population se réfugiera
encore plus de philoponnes il faudra
attendre 1954 pour que ça soit interdit
après le meurtre d'une jeune écolière
par un addict de 20 ans concrètement ça
fait quoi dans ton corps vous vous
souvenez du mur de serrure qui tapissent
l'extrémité de vos neurones tout autour
où vous avez plein de signaux chimiques
qui essayent de s'y emboîter d'avoir la
bonne clé et malheureusement beaucoup
échouent alors au lieu de les laisser là
flotter dans le vide les neurones vont
envoyer des transporteurs pour les
capturer histoire de les stocker et de
le réutiliser plus tard mais qu'est-ce
qui se passe et si on bloquait ces
transporteurs votre cerveau ne pourrait
plus évacuer le surplus et vous serez
noyé sous les informations c'est comme
ça qu’agissent les amphétaminer la
cocaïne vous vous sentez fort et envahi
de plaisir mais en réalité votre cerveau
est victime d'un stress intense et les
cellules s'abîment à cause du surplus
d'information en analysant des cerveaux
de cocaïnoman chronique on a découvert
qu'il vieillissait deux fois plus vite à
cause des nombreuses cellules perdues le
cerveau finit donc par s'atrophier
augmentant le risque d'AVC et de
maladies neurodégénératives c'est la
même chose pour la MDMA qu'on trouve
dans les ecstasies sauf qu'en plus de
bloquer les transporteurs ça libère un
max de sérotonine d'où les petits effets
psychédéliques que n'a pas la cocaïne
avec les lignes qui se déforment des
sens plus aiguisées une plus grande
sociabilité pour la pourquoi on
l'appelle la drogue de l'amour par
contre la descente le moment où la
drogue est éliminée par le corps bah
elle est souvent très violente un
toboggan en favorise la dépression en
prenant du MDMA vous vous empêchez sa
recapture et donc vider vos stocks il
reste plus rien walou résultat après la
soirée un gros sentiment de déprime
pendant plusieurs jours malgré tous ces
défauts les amphétamines sont encore
utilisés comme médicament par exemple la
Ritaline ou latéral pour traiter les
TDAH troubles de l'attention et de
l'hyperactivité des gens comme moi qui
sont incapables de se concentrer plus de
5 minutes même dans une pièce vide on
sait pas comment ça marche on sait juste
que les amphétamines permettent de
réduire les symptômes mais du coup c'est
quoi une drogue dans l'ensemble les
drogues fonctionnent toutes de la même
manière elles vont mimer des processus
que ton cerveau sait déjà faire
naturellement juste en les amplifiant ce
qui va rompre l'équilibre pour le
rétablir bah oui prenez les
antidépresseurs ça agit exactement comme
une drogue par exemple en empêchant la
recapture de la sérotonine ce qui peut
être une cause de la dépression on en
revient à ce que disait par alcès tout
est rien n'est poison c'est la dose qui
fait le poison entre drogues et
médicaments c'est une question de dose
et de contexte voilà pourquoi il faut
laisser la recherche étudier ces
substances elles sont mauvaises parce
qu'on les utilise mal mais en soi elles
sont neutres tout est déjà dans votre
cerveau dont on ne comprend toujours pas
le fonctionnement j'espère que ça vous a
permis de mieux comprendre de quoi on
parlait le but n'est pas du tout de vous
inviter à tester on a quand même
beaucoup parlé des effets négatifs on
vient de pas nous dire qu'on en fait la
promotion parce qu'on a parlé de science
ne prenait jamais rien qui modifie votre
corps sans consulter un médecin d'abord
si vous êtes déjà un consommateur vous
devez savoir ce qui se passe dans votre
tête et pourquoi vous êtes trompé
pourquoi c'est dangereux pour vous sur
le long terme et au grand public de
comprendre qu'il ne faut pas exclure
socialement ces gens pour les aider pas
à pas à rétablir un équilibre chimique
qui a été rompu ce ne sont pas des
déchets bons pour la poubelle ce sont
des humains disonnier d'une molécule
souvent issue de plantes naturelles
d'ailleurs qui a fait bugger quelque
chose en eux dans tous les cas
faites-vous aider ne restez pas seul
dans ce monde tout est science et elle
peut vous sauver